Now I know our work up to this point
with this yogurt data set has been review and it
should be, but let's hear from Dean about how we
might proceed differently with this type of a data set.
>> When familiarizing yourself with a new data set that
contains multiple observations of the same units, it's often useful
to work with a sample of those units so that
it's easy to display the raw data for that sample.
In the case of the yogurt data set, we might want to look at a small sample
of households in more detail so that we know
what kind of within and between household variation we
are working with. This analysis of a sub-sample might
come before trying to use within household variation as
part of a model. For example, this data set
was originally used to model consumer preferences for variety.
But, before doing that, we'd want to look at how often we observe households
buying yogurt, how often they buy multiple items, and what prices they're buying
yogurt at. One way to do this is to look at some sub-sample
in more detail. Let's pick 16 households at random and take a closer look.